hello everyone and welcome back to the
2022 chess olympiad it is round six and
it is the clash you guys have been
waiting for on board one we have india
uh or rather india second team
versus uh the first border of armenia
gabriel sergio who is an incredibly
strong player he already won the olympia
the gold medal in the olympiad three
times fighting for armenia in 2006 and
2008 and 2012
and
he is most definitely a a a an
incredibly difficult opponent for lukas
and i'm not going to spoil anything uh
regarding the game i will however say
that it is uh extremely interesting and
that it really shows you how to prepare
for a chess game so let's uh check it
out and see what happened here lukas has
the white pieces and he opens with d4 we
have d5 c4
going for the queen's gambit we have e6
declining the gambit knight f3 knight f6
and now knight to c3 and of course
bishop to b4 again we have the aragos in
defense
and bishop to g5 and c characters on d5
are the standard replies here but goku
goes for queen to a for with check it's
not extremely rare or anything it's just
that the the other moves are uh you know
a bit more common so knights to c6
blocking check and defending the bishop
on b4 and pawn to e3 we have castles by
gabriel
and bishop to d2 d captures on c4 we
have bishop captures on c4 and now
bishop back to d6 again this is all very
standard preparing e5 as the white king
is still in the center of the board uh
so queen back to c2 and now uh pawn to
e5 we have d captures on e5 knight
captures on e5 and this is where things
get extremely interesting and why i said
that um
the game really shows you how to prepare
for a chess game against a very strong
opponent there is only one move that
absolutely everyone plays here and that
is knight captures on e5 this is the
only move uh you play here because if
you allow the engine to crunch the
numbers in this position the engine will
tell you only two moves are playable for
white one is bishop back to e2 as your
bishop is also hanging on c4 so you want
to play bishop to e2 or the other one is
knight captures on e5 and the engine
slightly prefers knight captures on e5
and that's why everyone in this position
plays knight captures an e5 but it's a
very forced line and
well you don't really enjoy playing it
with white i will show you very quickly
if you play what the engine suggests a
knight captures bishop captures f4 sort
of fighting for advantage but black will
not allow you to just safely castle
black will give up the bishop bishop
captures and go knight to g4 now
threaten to pick up the e3 pawn and
after bishop to d4 now black is the one
who will start the attack pawn to c5
sacrificing a pawn bishop captures rook
e8 and already it is black who's
attacking here now this has all been
thoroughly analyzed and no one will
actually win this i mean
most of the games do end in a draw from
this position
but it's uh
definitely not a way to look for chances
with white so here gookish instead of
going for knight captures on e5 like i
said the move that absolutely everyone
plays in this position just goes back
bishop to e2 and it is now as of movie
11 that we have a completely new game so
how do you continue playing here and
it's very interesting that already with
this retreat uh he completely confused
the sergian as it would seem uh people
never check uh really check the
discontinuation because no one ever
played it and it you know it makes no
sense to play it so here the engine will
tell you you can play c6 you can play
queen e7 bishop d7 rook to e8 those are
moves that you would come up with
yourself you just have to continue
development however here sergion says uh
all right uh let's see what what what
you have planned out uh knight captures
on f3 and here he gives gucci a dare
does he just want to capture with the
bishop or does he want to play g
characters on f3 completely imbalance
the position and uh will grab the
semi-open g file to be used uh to attack
the black king and as you might have
suspected uh this is exactly what goku
does g captures on f3 and now we already
have an
extremely interesting game
so here uh of course sargassian
realizes that uh gurgash will not be
castling kingside he will however be
castling queen side so he prepares his
expansion he plays a6 now b5 b4 is
coming uh gookish quickly castles queen
side and ponte b5 now we have rook h the
g1 and ponta b4 chasing away the knight
with knight to e4 knight captures f
captures and now queen to e7 developing
the queen preparing to develop the
bishop connect the rooks and so on so
here pont f4 you can see that gurkish
now has a massive control over these uh
squares on the fifth franc here he has
the semi open g5 for his rook he's going
to double up rooks on the g file most
likely and he will of course try to
attack the black king uh and sergey sion
will try to attack the white king on the
queen side so pawn to a5 and now pawn to
e5 attacking the bishop bishop to c5 and
now
getting the rook off of the g1 square he
goes rook to g5 preparing to double up
on the g file also maybe interesting is
uh
because you know if you double up on the
g file he will play g6 at some point so
maybe bishop
to d3 is a very nice way to actually ask
black how are you defending here are you
playing h6 are you playing g6 uh because
the immediate g6 might just be giving a
target
at the white also you know it's uh
uh maybe a nice move to to throw in but
lukas has a different plan he goes rook
to g5 he says this is not not necessary
uh bishop to a6 immediately uh tackling
this bishop not allowing bishop to d3
rook d the g1 and now g6 stopping of
course rook captures and g7 and here we
have bishop characters and a6 rook
captures on a6 and pawn to f5 and this
is where the game completely explodes
and where i will show you guys why chess
is the greatest game that was ever
invented and probably ever will be
here black has to play something and
it's definitely not pleasant look at
these pawns controlling all of these
squares i mean that's not something you
want to face
obviously this pawn is free for grabs
but if you capture this pawn then f
captures on g6 opens up a discovery on
your queen also your position is just
crumbling here
so you're not gonna do that however uh
there is one move for black and i i
could ask you to pause the video but
it's such a disgusting engine line you
guys will feel like i'm tricking you so
like if you really want to you can pause
the video here and try to find the only
good move for black but you know better
better don't do it you know you're going
to go mad
so uh here the only good move for black
is rook to c6 it looks uh pointless as
the rook is not even defended on c6 but
now that you see it of course the queen
and king and on the c file there might
be something here and if the queen comes
to e8 for example then there will be all
sorts of nasty discoveries to be made
with this bishop so here the game might
might continue king to b1 queen to e8
now again uh threatening some nasty
discoveries now the rook is defended
queen to e4 we're going to get our queen
out of the way and now queen to d7
attacking the bishop here but now pawn
to e6 and you can never afford to
capture here because then white just
starts uh capturing and
black is destroyed so here we would see
f captures on e6 f captures and g6 now
pawn to h6 we have to keep the g file
closed rook to h5 and now queen captures
on d2 so black would win a bishop here
g7
attacking the rook here and it seems
like black just resigns here however
there is the possibility of rook to f1
with check
very very important as it leaves the g7
pawn undefended after white captures
here rook captures on f1 now bishop
captures an f3 uh on e3 threatening to
sacrifice the queen queen c1 check and
then rook to c1 checkmate so you have to
play something the problem is uh there
is really no good move to make here uh
except one if you captured the rook
which is kind of what you can do then
queen d3 check and you just get
checkmated queen to c2 we're gonna
capture here and after queen c1 this
will be checkmate so that's out of the
question you can't capture this rook
what you can do is play rook to c5 a
white counters with a brilliancy much
like black did when playing rook to f1
rook to c5 and now
you can't capture with the rook because
queen captures an e6 and black gets
checkmated you cannot capture with the
bishop um
also queen to f3 and now you no longer
have control over the c file now just
the queen to f7 and it's game over uh so
this cannot be defended what you can do
is play bishop to d4 this is kind of the
only way that you can continue fighting
for uh for for something but now comes
queen to c2 you threaten to to capture
the queen and to capture the rook on c6
and here black is forced to trade queen
captures through captures now let's say
rook captures king captures and after
king captures in g7 you would get this
end game where it's a rook and three
points against the bishop and five pawns
maybe you can win this maybe not um you
know it's uh hard to say with perfect
play probably it's winning um
but uh it's very very hard to
to actually pull this off
so this is what might happen if you
actually play the best move rook to c6
which again if any of you found in i
mean truly congratulations you are you
are beyond brilliant uh but here bishop
to a7 was played and now uh there uh is
a way to you know just start winning
this with white uh and here we have
ponta e6 right away king the b1 the
engine uh really prefers this as you do
not want your king and queen on the c
file uh but it seems that um uh gurkish
manages to trick sargisian
into overly defending and he plays king
the h8 here uh to actually survive this
you just have to play f captures on e6
and after g6 h6 now attack the rook g7 h
captus and g5 captures here with
queening uh king captures and now you
have this position where the black king
is exposed but so is the white king and
with you know some decent play uh you
should not be able to win this however
after e6 king the h8 was played getting
the king off of the g file but now goku
plays king to b1 and now the attack
starts now again it's incredibly
important to do this because if you just
start capturing e captures on f7 now
there's the problem of the e3 pawn
bishop captures an e3 and after i have
characters and g6 you can just capture
here with check and this is not a
problem queen captures h captures and g6
rook captures for example rook captures
rook characters now you think you are
checkmating the black king but just real
captures an f7 and that's it if queen h6
check you can defend and this is now a
dead draw so lukas plays it correctly he
plays king to b1 you have to play this
move and now comes g captures on f5 uh
giving uh glucose the open g file and
basically saying uh there is only one
way that will allow you to win the game
cleanly uh but it's not an easy one to
spot so feel free to pause the video and
win the game for goo cash while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh
yet again realizing that it has
something to do with the b4 square and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is bishop captures on b4 we
can do it also in slow motion if you
guys want uh yeah the point is we have
to move uh the obstacle uh that is
preventing our queen from reaching g2
but we also want to do it with tempo uh
so the tempo is attacking the queen if
black just ignores this moves the queen
then we can even capture the rook uh so
queen captures on b4 it doesn't really
matter what you play here the game is
now completely winning for white and now
queen the g2 threatening rook the g8 uh
of course through captures and queen
captures will be checkmate so here queen
to e4 with check uh sergician manages to
trade off the queens but it doesn't
matter as the game is still tactically
completely winning for gookish queen
captures f captures and now the only
winning move but not a difficult one the
spot pawn to e7 uh and that's it uh here
the rook is attacked you have to move
the rook rook to e8 was played but now
just rook to g8 with check rook captures
rook captures king captures and e8 the
pawn again becomes a queen and now you
have a queen against the bishop and rook
but the bishop and rook are so awkwardly
placed that it's very unlikely that
black will be able to organize his
forces to you know prevent some sort of
a
quick check and uh you know
just picking up the rook or the bishop
so here of course the game continued
king g7 queen to e5 check we have rook
to f6 and now uh not going for rook
captures on a5 right away but first a
nice classy move queen to g5 with check
now this is very forcing you can't go
away because you lose the rook so you
have to play rook to g6 and now you play
queen captures on a5 by doing this
little maneuver you are now preventing
bishop captures an e3 because now the
bishop captures queen c3 check picks up
the bishop so it wasn't uh you know just
to give a check
planned this out very nicely so he could
grab the a5 pawn without worrying about
his e3 pawn because if the e3 pawn uh
you know isn't here then this pawn
becomes dangerous so here rook the g1
with chuck king c2 rook the g2 with
check king to b3 and now bishop to b6 as
the bishop was hanging here so queen to
e5 with check
king to f8 now queen to h8 to check king
the e7 and queen captures on h7 giving
uh sergician the move but there really
aren't all that many moves he goes for
rook to e2 his only chance is to pick up
this pawn and create a past e pawn but
now uh well now a few checks and this
rook will not survive for very long
queen captures an e4 with check king the
f8 and queen to be for check and he was
in this position on move 41 upon
reaching time control that gabriel
sergician resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here gokus wins
yet another game this is his sixth win
in a row so currently lukas in the chess
olympiad is six out of six which is
absolutely incredible uh and here you
resign because if of course king eight
then queen b5 check picks up the rook
and if you go to the g file anywhere
doesn't really matter where uh you can
play king g7 then queen to g for check
again picks up the rook this way so of
course now
that would be pointless the only thing
you can do to save the rook is play c5
which forces uh you to capture the
bishop but you are very happy with the
bishop i mean queen versus rook here is
completely winning so you know whatever
you get to take rook or bishop it will
be perfectly fine uh so yeah that's the
game i hope you guys uh enjoyed it uh
some of you said that um uh that i am
mistaking about glucose
rating here as i'm uh saying it's 2684
but
i i always imagine that people know this
uh there is this uh thing called the
live ratings and there is this thing
called the current actual ratings which
is updated like once a month or maybe
once in two months i know it was updated
once every two months now maybe it's
like once a month i'm pretty sure it's
once once a month now uh but he's over
2700 in the live rating so if you guys
are interested in
uh what's his current trading now uh it
is exactly
point
27
so he is currently uh you know uh
since the last rating list he's up
twenty point three points which is
incredible he's currently twenty sixth
in the world uh and he overtook vidit uh
we already said that in the previous
video but now he also overtook sam
shankland uh
getting that 26th spot in the world next
is
nikita vitigo topalov
andreikin harikrishna
and so on it's a long way to the top but
i mean gucci is six out of six if he
continues this i mean uh that's uh i
mean it's absolutely incredible that he
can play like this and it all came down
to his incredible tactical style and
absolutely elegant preparation it's like
uh it's like you know
what what what you would expect from
maybe fabiano caruana some some 10 years
ago uh you know just uh knight captures
on e5 and then not going for what
everyone plays just bishop back to e2
the move no one plays because the engine
said so so you know be careful when
playing something just because the
engine said so
uh so once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it we're gonna cover some other
games from round six as uh games are
getting uh
more and more interesting by the day uh
i would like to thank esmondalde and
jacob tobias der king felix daffo and
casey wins for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to
cover the olympiad until it finishes so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day